[Musik]
marion und elias place wollte listen ist
verbranntes essen wirklich krebserregend
eine wichtige frage die linie zum anfang
der krise nord lehren soll
gegrilltes essen ist im leckere sachen
doch vor allem wenn es schön
frauenbildes dabei wird uns ständig von
braun gebrannte messen abgeraten aber
warum eigentlich fangen wir mit den
vegetariern an wenn gemüse stark erhitzt
wird wie zum beispiel beim grillen
findet ab so circa 140 grad celsius die
sogenannte maja reaktion stadt die ich
euch in unserem backe video ist eine
meine lieblings reaktion vorgestellt
hatte die maya habt sie uns eine
reaktion zwischen zuckern und proteine
die für ganz viele leckere aromastoffe
sowie zum beispiel beim rösten von
kaffee oder beim backen von plätzchen
oder eben auch beim grill bei gemüse
entsteht aber durch die reaktion mit der
aminosäure asparagin ein erstes produkt
und zwar acrylamid aktuell damit ist die
sich und krebserregend allerdings sind
die mengen für die eine schädlichkeit
nachgewiesen wurde viel höher als die
menge der beim grillen zu uns nehmen für
die konzentration an der kohle mit etwas
essen zu uns nehmen konnte eine
vergleichsstudie keine zusammenhänge mit
den meisten krebs ort feststellen
fleischesser haben ein anderes problem
und zwar eine andere war reaktion in
fleisch und fisch ist kreative teil
dass sich in der reaktion zu sogenannten
heterozyklischen aromatischen aminen
kurzhaar es um banden kann und bei der
unvollständigen verbrennung von
organischem material zum beispiel von
holz oder und fleisch entstehen
sogenannte polyzyklische aromatische
kohlenwasserstoffe kurz pak
sowohl-als-auch pass sind
nachgewiesenermaßen krebs ist aber noch
nicht geklärt ob bei gegrilltem fleisch
diese konzentration bereits schädlich
sind sicher ist beim grillen entstehen
krebserregende stoffe ob die jetzt für
uns schon schädlich sind sind der
konzentration
das ist noch nicht nachgewiesen man kann
um einen gift nie unabhängig von der
dosis betrachten es wäre sicher auch ein
gift aber es kann sicherlich nicht
schaden den mais oder das deck nicht
unbedingt schön schwarz zu vielen
schönen schwarz nicht außerdem fanden
forscher heraus dass wir im gegensatz zu
neandertalern eine genmutation
entwickelt haben die uns feuer und rauch
besser vertragen lässt die genmutation
sorgt dafür dass die giftigkeit von p nk
durch unser stoffwechsel verringern
jetzt so dass der moderne mensch
verbranntes essen wie auch feuer rauch
besser verträgt als seine vorfahren dann
haben uns doch irgendwie zu grillen
menschen entwickelt in diesem sinne
bruce grill schön schlaf
wie hat ihr am liebsten euer essen
schöne dampfbad gleich geboren oder
schöne schwarz schreibt in die
kommentare zusammen mit euren fragen und
themen vorschlägen wir sehen uns nächste
woche fürs grillen und frisst einen
platz sicher